i feel so bad about how bad we're
roasting you um
[Music]
hi welcome to another episode of big
moves
uh we have our oh gosh she's so pretty
we have our
beautiful
oh look at her our beautiful guest tell
them who baby tell them who
nikki blades baby you made her introduce
herself
she just loves listening to me talk to
her
you know my name you'll say it later
excuse me everybody got excited what's
up ladies you know i love being here
with you guys by the way so we love
having you oh i love you all it's a
great day when nikki blaze is here yeah
and for our listeners we also have jess
and tiff and baby
it's gonna be another one of those fun
episodes where i get to judge i mean uh
we get to
um look at your dating profiles and you
know tell tell you how we feel about it
uh we put out a thing on the big mood
girls instagram i'm asking for you guys
big mood girls at big mood girls we
asked you guys to send in your profiles
and you know you might get a chance to
be on the episode so a few lucky people
are going to be in the episode today i
am sorry for the things that i'm about
to say about your profile
but let's just let's just jump right
into it yeah let's do it all right so
okay uh we're keeping everything
anonymous and this person's nikki make
him make him a name this is sean sean
okay yeah i like how that was a normal
ass yeah super darn the last time we did
this
sean yeah
[Music]
no no oh this is um slackdaddy278
okay there we go slack daddy we got
slackdaddy278 and upon pulling up his
friends already know why he called him
the daddy yeah
okay so the first
uh photo we got here what was his
message oh you want to read the message
yeah what do you say okay slack daddy
says hey girls i've been a big fan of
you guys ever since you started the
podcast thank you for showing different
perspectives of the women's views and
different opinions here's my profile i
hope it shows who i am and what i want
in a relationship thank you parentheses
not gay
why did you feel the need to say not gay
that's what i want to know i think it's
maybe because of the fact that in
previous episodes we've always had to be
like i don't know what he is maybe he's
gay
yeah okay you don't know there's usually
the dating profiles will have like a
thing where you can put straight or gay
but actually not the ones i was looking
through i was like i think you can
either hide it yeah like you can hide it
or show it or you choose what you want
to show up and what you're going to do
yeah profiles yeah okay slack daddy
slack daddy hmm right off the bat what
do we think ladies the first picture
here what are we seeing
i see why we call him daddy
i'm not mad i'm not mad at it but i'm
like
i'm gonna scroll with the [ __ ] wince
in my face like what's coming now off
tops first thing i'm getting
you've done this before
you you probably have a really pop in
instagram he's probably a model i get
model vibes like models guys
take good photos like this don't don't
pump up his ego okay men suck it all
right
it's literally
this is a perfect dating profile photo
like i'm looking at it he's well dressed
he looks put together he has an
aesthetic like he thought this through
and i appreciate the effort that he put
in but i'm already mad looking at it
because i'm like what kind of [ __ ] am i
okay
if i'd match with this guy now what's
his little quote saying okay so the
prompt is from the dating app says all i
ask is that you dot dot dot he said
all i ask is that you
uh to be open the grammar is not working
for me all right she's already youtube
he's speaking hey he's speaking my
language fix the grammar boy fix your
grammar uh he asks hey baby it sounded
right it's a one it's a whole scene
it needs to make sense all i ask is that
you are open to new things like fix it
please unless you want to attract girls
that are open to your background
you might be fighting [ __ ] like me
out yeah
maybe i don't know how to properly use a
comma either
or a period he ain't even got a period
damn you gotta close a sentence for this
actually nikki can i get a glass of wine
because i feel like i need to roast
people with a glass of wine please thank
you
all right me too
all right there we go uh all i ask is
that you okay ask for someone to be open
to new things and with an open heart
to have an amazing conversation you use
the wrong a the a before a vowel is
supposed to be an a and what are you
talking about do you have an open heart
oh i was looking at the one before an
amazing conversation okay well but
besides let's see he's got it right in
the second yeah
can we get into the amazing behind it
yeah he wants i know you guys can't get
past the ground i know
i know with his grandma i know i could
you imagine those text conversations
though like everybody's confused yeah
like the [ __ ] are we talking you know
what i mean you know what i'm getting
from this though the dick's so good he
didn't have to learn how to spell
everything he didn't have to learn how
to spell no one gives a name that
right we're mad at how good this photo
is so we're already like god damn it
[ __ ] you thank you slack daddy
thank you thank you go get yourself
something nice
hey she came out of retirement for this
one
ladies cheers okay so can i see the
second the next one okay i want another
photo here we go oh so far we're getting
an aesthetic yeah i like it hold on wait
what's this
seven what is that low
now you should have learned how to use a
proper punctuation because you're gonna
have to compensate for your height
that's messed up all right so he's 20
years old he's five seven
uh southeast oh wait i can't say where
he's from no in texas low voltage
electrician what is that even that's too
specific
so yeah
he works on little
tiny batteries
okay look i feel like you're somewhere
in texas based on this profile because
we're not going to give away exactly
where you're going yet i feel so bad
about how bad we're roasting you uh
we're roasting you because you're b.j
how about that
wow i'm trying to balance out how mean
we've been today
all the guys are going to start like
submitting their profile
i saw the low voltage electrician and i
i judged it and then i thought he's got
electricity in his life all of a sudden
he was like you can cancel girls like me
out of that because you don't know how
let me take back my height comment that
was low-hanging fruit yeah if i'm just
looking at the photo yo you're winning
right now in my book this is great you
look well traveled very stylish cool can
i see his face though well really quick
though say how tall you are again i'm
five nine okay so that's the reason and
i'm not super tall but i love to wear
heels yeah i am about six foot in heels
for you personally perfect decision
i'm five nine
four yeah yeah to me that like cool the
average height for a man in the u.s is
five nine that is the average so an
average height for a woman is five four
to five i'm average five yeah it's about
five four that's me yeah so i mean
completely he is i'm not sure that's
just me talking my ex is the same height
as this guy short kings need love too
they do not for me but you need to
totally she's not for me okay and it's
not like i said it's not because there's
something wrong with you it's because
i'm weak and gina loves tall queens
but yes great photo absolutely i have no
can we see his face we are roasting you
because right off the bat in your first
photo you're just too good you're so
he's into a photography adventures
that's what i'm reading off of this guy
me in the wild it's a picture of him
with the hand oh no what is that
paddleboard
nope i'm out i don't like physical
people don't you make me go outside oh
my gosh
because i'm like
just loving this one i love it
but also i don't like that he's not in
the photo but i enjoy it again there's
this is this aesthetic part of his
personality i am giving this like yo
you're winning right now it's a great
instagram photo but on a dating profile
i need as much evidence as i can get of
who you are
for me this does give me who he is yes
it doesn't give me what he looks like
because he's not interested in you just
like what he looks like for you did you
just sign out for me this picture is
useless okay yeah like i i can i would
scroll right past it yeah i don't give a
[ __ ] about aesthetic [ __ ] that's for
instagram that's not what i'm here for
for aesthetic [ __ ] so it's just about
who okay so slack daddy get rid of that
photo slap daddy okay
man out because i like it
oh nick
agrees with me i like you do you like it
too the nikkies can share mike i like it
because it makes me feel like i'm there
with him exactly and and it also gives
me clues on the type of person he is and
like what
i can experience
yeah like from his perspective and like
as a scorpio we like to know as much
about you before we even talk to you
as we can and so i'm like okay he likes
paddle boarding in the city oh with a
view he likes photography okay i got a
lot of information
pictures pictures worth a thousand words
right you can also connect your
instagram and your instagram indeed
we'll scroll down
i don't need this [ __ ] off camera thank
you what happened no i just you know i'm
just saying thousands making up [ __ ]
a thousand words make up one photo words
listen meanings word something of that
one yes
you'll have to excuse us it's our last
episode of the night we're just going
crazy okay i'm ready for the next photo
because i think i'm just gonna wait
but the prompt says i'm trying to help
you girl because i see his face i want
someone who and he goes
he says i want someone who challenges me
to do more and who loves to take risks
there's two who's in there there's one
on one risks
there's just one there loves to take
risks
show this wondrous who challenges me
more than who feels to take no she just
wants to see this manchester united and
do something he just wants to
participate okay look there's a lot that
is off the table when the grammar is
this bad a relationship is off you just
offer
about how bad the grammar is but how
good he looks in this pair of slacks
that i'm like i can use i could do
something
this guy is a pretty boy who just likes
to have adventures who has an artistic
side grammar is not important no it's
i'm just imagining right now i'm just
writing a sticker like whose dick is
this and he goes yours while you are
eating
he speaks in rhythm i mean that's why
his grammar's so bad you like it she's
playing with her hair yo okay we need to
see
his face this man is about to make a
fake account and talk [ __ ] on all right
no no
no no no no no she's about to slide into
this man's dna no no no
no no no no no no okay
it's a video it's a video it's a video
it's a video
he might be salvageable and comic fan
that's cool okay that's not dorky though
so stop trying to be cute with it being
dorky
where's your face here we go we gotta
taste
see he's attractive i told you he was a
pretty boy no i gotta be even more mean
this is not a parallel we gotta knock
him down a few notches how my friends
see me what's up
he's a good looking man yeah he is yeah
i'm upset by that yeah i'm kind of mad
see i'm also he's only 20 so he's like
way out
of my age range i'm gonna have to put
grapefruit in this glass
juice like what am i supposed to drink
juice beverly has a good head of hair
some good eyebrows good facial hair
lipstick hair his
look i checked the stats i like looking
at you just not quite for me yeah
but i'm giving this dating profile like
you're getting a seven eight like you're
definitely not going to be on the market
for long like you have options he's
wasting the photos with the outdoor [ __ ]
like i don't give a [ __ ] i don't feel
like it's a waste because he is
attractive i feel like because he is
attractive it could become i know i'm
hot if it's just photos of him every
single time because we've seen
this yes
i felt like he broke it up yeah and that
to me makes me want to keep scrolling
i like and then even though the grammar
wasn't there i liked what he wrote for
his prompts yeah like i would spark a
cro
it allows to spark a conversation yeah
but just please fix the grammar so that
a girl doesn't swipe left on you over
something so stupid i mean but if she
swipes
over a comma isn't that stupid
the whole thing's all [ __ ] up like
there was red lines all over that shirt
those are your red flags no it's not a
red flag but i it's like when i i want
to respect someone and when there's just
so
i'm never texting you
just like your respect [ __ ] don't move
me in that group in a relationship like
with a guy that i'm going to be dating i
don't care about my friends
i don't care about my friends grammar at
all yeah but like yeah if i i just want
to respect you and i'm like oh you
have the
intellect of a high schooler like you
yeah no i understand it's not attractive
but also if it's if english is not his
first language then i don't care yeah oh
[ __ ] did we just get racist by accident
here then all of us god damn it if
english is not your first language we'll
let it's like yeah then that's then at
that point i don't care because
obviously that's why and if english is
your first language you just need to
work on your grammar a little bit you
know what it is it's the lack of
attention to detail because this is your
face forward you're trying to date
someone details i understand that i
wanted to i want to know that you put
effort into this because you want to
make a good first impression but this
you're hot but you also sound like you
really if you did finger under each word
if you didn't even
think
tiff and i are looking at it for the
meaning like what he meant by it and i
see i totally see where you guys are
coming from so i would say fix your
grammar like proof read before you post
don't you want a guy that puts effort
into like most things
if if he's not even gonna put enough
effort
it depends on what your priorities are
so that's your priority just to me the
meaning but but i understand that
going to matter in my foreign because if
not i'm going to be nitpicking at every
little [ __ ] thing how often are you
reading emails from this guy no no
that's gonna he's gonna be the guy that
doesn't put attention to detail into a
lot of other things in our life and
that's really gonna [ __ ] piss me off
and for me and if i'm just evaluating
the profile i say proofread because the
meaning behind it was great like i think
everything else i like the other photos
i feel like it balances out he's very
attractive too it gave me some like
depth but just proofread before you post
venmo me 20 bucks i'll do it for you
20.
i should send you my tweets because i'll
be smelling everything
i get told hey yo drunky stop trying to
drink me
because you ain't smelling nothing right
so i feel you he is really looking at me
right now yeah yeah okay we can take
that down yeah he's just staring at me
is there any other stuff like this man
that would not have any trouble you're
fine yeah
and i love how the first photo is like
out of his like
zoomed out and then you get to his face
you're like damn because i could only
imagine if that was the first photo i
would be like
okay this is a great first photo great
for you
he's like i'm waiting for you are you
are you ready for dinner yeah i think i
would disagree with you guys with what i
in terms of that being the first photo i
would pick the one with the sun in his
face as the first photo that is that
that captures me and like
knowing what he already looks like you
know
you know it's all about like image he's
looking right into the camera the other
photo of him being like super model like
further away like that to me screams
like like conceited and like i wouldn't
want to keep scrolling i wouldn't want
to get to know this guy yeah it's
possible for me personally i would pick
the sun in his face that is a really
good photo shout out to your selfie
slack daddy you could go ahead and slide
that one up to the top yeah look at him
just golden hour
if you're sleeping on a terrible
mattress your sleep will be terrible
it's that simple that's why i recommend
sleeping on a purple mattress purple
mattresses are the only mattresses that
have the gel flex grid i don't know if
you've seen it but it's a super stretchy
ultra squishy type of material that it
adapts and if it flexes around your
pressure points and it doesn't retain
heat which is great for if you're like a
night sweater type of person and you get
really hot during the night i like it a
lot because i have chronic back pain
issues and i always always wake up with
a sore back when i started sleeping on
the purple mattress that significantly
relieved my back pain and i cannot
recommend it enough so try your purple
mattress risk free with free shipping
and returns financing is available as
well if you want that and getting a
great night's sleep starts with having a
great mattress get a purple mattress go
to purple.com bigmood10 and use code
bigmu10 for a limited time you can get
10 off any order of 200 or more that's
purple.com
big mood10 code bigmood10 for 10 off any
order of 200 or more purple.com
big mood 10 promo code big mood 10 terms
apply you know when my cats are healthy
they're happy and that makes me happy
but since i'm not a mind reader i don't
always know when my cats are healthy
helping me know my cat's health is just
one of the reasons why i have been using
pretty litter for well over a year now i
absolutely love it it's such good kitty
litter i am such a huge fan and my
kitties love it too because they're so
soft like the crystals are so soft on
the pads of their paws and they're just
really loving it and i love how it just
absorbs all of the urine all you have to
do is scoop up the poop and the fact
that it actually can tell me the health
of my cats it's a huge deal for me so
with pretty litters ultra absorbent
crystals it traps odor instantly so no
more cat bathroom smell pretty litter's
super light crystal base also minimizes
mess and dust plus the crystals last up
to a month which means less scooping and
fewer trips to the garbage can here's
the coolest thing about pretty litter
though it changes colors to help detect
early signs of potential illness in my
cats including urinary tract infections
and kidney issues and pretty litter
ships free to my door in a small
lightweight bag and i never run out of
it and i don't have a huge container of
litter taking up space and stinking up
my place pretty litter helps keep my
cats healthy and keeps odors down you
and your cat are going to love pretty
litter as much as we do you have to go
to
prettylitter.com and use code big mood
in order for you to get 20 off your
first order that's prettylitter.com
use code bigmood for 20 off
prettylitter.com code big mood all right
so slack daddy uh you know what you're
doing good
you're fine he's great you just wanted
[ __ ] accolades yeah we had to knock
you down a few notches you web killed
[ __ ]
last time we were doing this we were
saying what kind of girl would would be
swiping right on this
all of them yeah
all of them but jess
huh no no just all no english teachers
yeah
that's why whatever she saw a low level
what low level low voltage electrician
and all of a sudden she was on her knees
i'm like damn [ __ ] not even like a
hello it wasn't even that it wasn't even
that no i was just like
he deserves more than this [ __ ]
[ __ ] over him being five seven
mm-hmm
i just i am she's fighting she's
fighting for them but now it's just like
i want to message you on instagram and
just like compliment you but also bully
you at the same time
yeah oh click on his ig i wanna see what
it looks like but i also but i also want
to
ask you what is low voltage he's online
right now i'm about to message oh [ __ ]
don't stay active now i also oh
models galilee i don't like the facial
hair though i love the facial hair i
like it too i wouldn't like it
personally okay
i bet he got something
hold on wait i know this man got some
shirtless photos on his instagram
he's too clean for 20. what's going on
this man looks 42 yeah what is the thing
i got a whole mortgage right now
yeah what's the photo
you got veins in your head looking like
stress like
sunday funding with the nieces
he knows what he's doing yes he knows he
knows what he's doing he's baby baby
let's get out get out of there go this
boy [ __ ] god
i know he [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] i know he [ __ ] oh god oh sir
what did i say i said i know there's a
shirtless photo on this page somewhere
i'm about to cyber bully you so hard
because you don't deserve all this love
wow you don't deserve it men don't
deserve it wow all right we need to move
from this guy
[Music]
the one thing that bothers me i will
just say this he is 20. yeah it bothers
me how grown he looks yeah because i
understand the fashion model stuff
and i love it but to me that looks like
a grown ass if you think it's kind of
like a mask
i want to know what's yeah it's not what
he looks like he might be just his job
who's oh he got tattoos yeah can we get
off of this man let's go to women we
need the women
he's doing it for us okay
can we get off on this
all right get me out of here i'm out
we're out we're out safety you're
winning at life you and you know it so
[ __ ] off and you're so young okay our
next one can we go to a woman i need a
comment yeah okay okay let's see
the next one is actually someone that i
know
oh really
i can't believe she's cute okay so oh my
god okay i can't wait to send this in
but this is uh this is my girlfriend
give her a name sweet tea sweet sweet
sweet tv sweetie i work with her at g4
oh she's cute she's really cute cute so
her what she does at g4 is she wrangles
the talent she tells us that's a fun job
this is where you need to be right now
that's fun
is
she wrangles us and she updates our
calendars to keep me on track okay yeah
all right uh okay oh she's so cute oh by
the way she's like tiny are you telling
us too much information
so what's her
i can't see that far so what does that
say her profile says my mantra is
the only negativity allowed in 2021 are
negative covid tests and then a tongue
tongue sticking out emoji yeah that's
cute that's really cute cute i like her
all right i wonder well yeah i just
wonder if in dating should you be
talking about covet testing
maybe it's really it could be like less
romantic though going because she's so
pretty and then we're like talking about
taking over tests yeah yeah i
honestly don't know if that's a good
opening line all right i would just say
i mean i see a beautiful woman right and
then i'm like she's like tamarco test it
just gets political real quick
yeah yeah yeah
like your mantra that's your mantra i
kind of want to know like i think what
she's showing is a sense of humor yeah
she's making light of a situation but i
would just be like oh okay
i don't i want it to hit a little bit
more if you're gonna you know really
show that side but yeah
it's a sensitive subject
covet is a sensitive subject maybe maybe
that's or maybe her mantra should be
something more about herself yes yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
maybe like that is
about her like it's that important to
her right because she's trying to weed
out people i wouldn't even entertain it
that's true yeah i mean
it bothers me when someone says i don't
like negativity i don't like drama
because then i'm like well why do you
have to say that
yeah just like not an openly opening
line if there was another like maybe if
it was burned down
yeah if my mantra came somewhere else
but just like we were talking about the
last guy yeah you know the first
impression yeah the first impression is
beautiful photos it's like 10 seconds
and then right there it's like i want
something else just about you mm-hmm i
agree yeah i agree so maybe her monster
should be something more personal no no
or just like mantra down lower
a little bit more personal let me get to
know you a bit more and then boom hit us
with that don't change your mantra if
that's your mantra baby that's your
mantra that's true how are you feeling
about the the this being her initial
profile photo adorable it's cute it's a
good one i like that it's up close and
we can see her face
the lighting is good the colors are
nice it's great okay next one is
her
her next photo is this oh that's cute i
would put that as a first one she is
tiny she's a tiny one teeny tiny yeah
she looks fun
like i want to go out with you mm-hmm
whether it's a date or like a friend or
whatever it is like that's a great photo
it pulls me in yeah you're laughing
you're dressed like you just look very
confident it's just screaming confidence
i love the brick wall like kind of like
the composition of the photo i really
like yeah i really like it a lot
yeah that would be a better first
picture that's what i'm saying
definitely make that one
she's 30 but in this photo i would have
picked like 22 or something like she
looks a lot younger like more like
youthful not that 30 isn't youthful but
you know what i mean i agree this should
be her she's radio yeah confidence
that's all i'm seeing is confidence fun
secure because the first photo looks
like it's planned ready once you maybe
yeah yeah yeah
but i get why it's there it's head
shotty to me
yeah yeah
that's true i want to hire her
yeah
all right let's see what
all right next one is this is her
okay
okay body shot thank you for it yeah
yeah yeah that really is like slightly
lex she's very very fit and yeah the
guys love to see that she's adventurous
yeah and what does it say we'll get
along if you're a big outdoors person
and beach person love it yeah outdoors
great great grammar mm-hmm
you guys see how she it's a whole
sentence
if you're an outdoor it goes together
she throws a couple emojis for the rest
of us you know what i'm saying like i
knew exactly what she was talking about
palm tree ocean
she likes outside
i think that captures her personality
yeah that's a great photo and it's like
it's exhausting for me that photo just
looks
like
i really also love and appreciate how
she's choosing photos that are warm like
well minus the first one it's like more
blue but still the fact that it's in the
sun well lit like it seems like a warm
inviting yeah maybe that's a note to
like even like change the shading of the
first one to a warmer color okay because
like the other two seem more impactful
already probably just because of the
warmth like the tone of the photo yeah i
agree how do you guys feel about because
every photo she has is a giant cheese
like how how do you feel more about like
changing it up a little bit i feel like
the first one is that's your personality
yeah well the first one's a different
smile than the last two and i felt like
every smile was different i'm i'm
getting do you like having some sultry
seriously i don't know yeah i'm trying
to get some dick but maybe she's a
little bit different
you're trying to get some dude yeah but
to me that's not who she is
the first photo looks like that's not
that's a planned photo it's not her
being herself the second one looks like
she's radiating this one she's
she's in her element yeah she's in her
element now right because you can see
when somebody's trying too hard that's
true yeah i think it'd be worse if
that's not really her personality to
take those serious photos and then she
tried that because i cringe on myself
when i take those i'm like this is so
not me but it doesn't work yeah yeah all
right on the final flip oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh that's the same she's smart read
what's up
says the one thing i'd love to know
about you is your taste in music but
plus music emojis
not only that this woman put in and
there's an nfl jersey on the jersey on
the dog which means
i like sports yeah that right there a
guy is going to be like okay you put the
pieces together this is someone that
you're not only going to want to date
but you're going to want to spend time
with this isn't just a saturday night
girl this is a sunday to sunday type of
girl right like you want to go to the
bar with her you want to go out to the
beach i want to enjoy her she
i
good job good job yeah
damn i didn't i didn't even notice that
little detail but that's that's gold
right there
straight to that i was like the doggy
has the nfl jersey i just saw jersey i
just saw sports
smart
you're like all right you know you might
turn i'm from texas so
uh
i just wish she was in that photo though
with her dog but i but again i'm not mad
i have photos of mine like the cutest
[ __ ] photos i i did take one and i
think i probably even said something
about not doing this but like i was like
i picked the cutest photo of my dog to
take up one photo just because i'm like
this is my life you know i like it i
think in dating profiles you're allowed
one nonfiction one throws one photo one
through one throw away your personality
[Laughter]
okay i'm all right next photo is here we
go family
family family looks like a mom and a is
that her dad or her brother i don't know
mom and dad i'm conflicted with this
photo like one looks like i'm with my
family in vegas
and
she's vegas she's going to be a lady in
the streets and a freak in las vegas
yeah okay well how do you feel about
other people even being in your dating
profile photos
i have friends once yeah but you kind of
blur their face a little remember
i feel conflicted with seeing somebody's
family right away in a dating profile
unless she's letting you know off tops
like family is a priority to me and you
have to like that in order to i'm not so
concerned about the family one is like a
ton of group photos where they're all
drinking all the time i think that to me
would be weird but like
showing that one photo i have friends
one photo this is my mom and i really
love her one photo this is like um me
out doing something cute at
at the [ __ ] canyon or whatever like
she was one photo she's just single and
like by the brick wall in her nice
little dress like it's it's a variety of
she gave us like who she is yeah this is
an overarching picture of her but it is
weird that the like the cutesy family
one that's right next to the party right
that's why i'm feeling conflicted but
her body i mean good for you yeah she's
a great body and she knows it too yeah
she knows it i know
i would have blocked out the family face
i don't like the family photos i always
cover the faces of other people i mean
but so many people online don't so i
don't know
maybe they feel weird about like
scratching out their mom's face or or
covering it but like it's kind of like
then why even post it yeah i guess yeah
but like i don't know how do you feel
about like these two photos me yeah um
my first reaction was like oh i don't
like these like take like they just i
don't like them but then the more i
analyzed it and then the more i took in
the the rest of the photos i'm like oh
it does paint a full picture of her
personality it does make me feel a
little weird that it's like super
churchy and then super party wild girl
next to each other but then there is a
compliment there so i am taking it all
in but my initial thing was i don't like
it take them out and do you think that
somebody swiping through a dating
profile would think because mind you you
only have a couple seconds
to capture somebody's attention i
wouldn't swipe away from that yeah
personally i probably wouldn't swipe
away okay because like a guy version of
that like if i see his mom and his
sister and then i see him with a couple
guys out but then like if the other
photos are like you know like this is me
in a suit or whatever you know like just
this is actually mimi
like on the rest of it like
it's okay for me to see like a little
bit of his actual life
a little bit like you know her a little
bit more yeah i'm like okay so she does
like to go out so she is fun but also
she can clean it up and you know go to
like a business function together and
she probably will know how to handle
herself in that space too full circle i
feel like yeah that's i i understand the
intention behind the profile i mean
i would just reorder them because it's
just jarring yeah yeah yeah the family
right
party looking one i get what she's
trying to convey like i can't you can
bring me home to parents but also i like
to party yeah but maybe uh the the
family photo maybe instead of including
family you have like just a nice photo
of you at like a wedding where you clean
up real nice and
you look yeah you could have been alone
in that photo probably yeah again
understand understand the journey of the
photos like because she's definitely
telling a story with all of these photos
but just initial reaction i am still i
still don't know how i feel about the
family yeah yeah again it's the
church it's saturday night
and sunday sunday yeah
i want to see your family right off the
bat like that
yeah i mean yeah i don't have my family
in any of my photos but i'm just saying
like when i see a guy showing his family
in his photos it doesn't bother me but
yeah i guess everyone feels differently
yeah
again i don't like the baby baiting
though that freaking annoys the [ __ ] the
baby all the guys have a photo with some
[ __ ] niece they borrowed to get the
photo yes look daddy [ __ ] that wasn't
that was amazing
that's true never mind i i respect the
fact that he didn't put his nieces on
his dating yeah that's baby baiting and
i [ __ ] can't stand that [ __ ] she
probably would have spelled it wrong
spelled nice or something i swipe
instantly when there's babies
the prompted day a day spent with my
nicest
nicest my nicest
okay we only got through two profiles
but then miss busybody superstar here
busy body blades yeah she's gotta hop on
a jet real quick i love you guys but
unfortunately y'all don't pay me enough
to quit my table
so till next time i wish i could girl
gotta go back and wake up in the morning
because i got work because i have to
provide for my baby morning radio you
know we got her here for four episodes
yeah well including this one i guess
three and a half so make sure you check
out the other episodes with her yeah
yeah you know where to find me they'll
tell you well we'll put it all in the
description link yes
i love you guys thank you for having me
shout out to all the profiles
y'all gotta [ __ ] chug your wine
whoa okay
i love you
i love
[Applause]
all right thank you so much
thank you everybody check her out
description box everything show them
girl and thanks for have for being with
us i love you so much but you guys don't
go away because nicki other nicki's
coming in nicki leave me coming in
i love you
i love you thank you so much we'll see
you next time think of me think think of
me
think of me
think of me call me or something i don't
know
i'll give you my number i will give you
my phone there you go
all right
and we're
[Applause]
[Music]
back on guys
i got some big shoes to feel phil uh
literally because her shoes are big
so
she's a tall queen we all need like a a
stunt double i feel like she was your
stunt double
maybe
okay we're casting uh sending directions
all right all right let's move on with
these profiles let's do who's next okay
we got a profile here he says hi big
movie wait what's his name oh that's
right nicky oh [ __ ] um
shrimp
master
what the let me see if sounds short i'm
sorry i was thinking of pasta i was
thinking of pasta and i was yeah
i'm sorry
the word shrimp should never be used to
describe any man about anything i wasn't
thinking of your height sir sir
come back come back i'm sorry man never
once said i'm so sorry
girl you just went from bed let's try to
figure something worse
i would be nicki's
uh under nikki's left foot oh there you
go
this is mickey's butler and he says
don't look at my butler
[Laughter]
all right uh nikki's butler says hi big
mood girls i want to start off by saying
thank you for all the content you've put
out i've been listening ever since the
beginning and i've learned so much from
listening to your podcasts i almost
never message the content creators i
watched but i've been really enjoying
the dating profile reviews and would
love to submit mine if you're still
doing yay
hey
you're getting in trouble for that
grammar yeah
we're still doing whatever it is
better serve me some shrimp alfredo
later
again she didn't say that because she
saw your profile she hadn't seen it yet
she just randomly said [ __ ]
hungry first profile picture oh he's
cute
i like the smile i wish the lighting was
better but the smile is yeah the
lighting is a little a scary story in
the campfire yes
blair witch yeah
i know that i know that a lot of guys
hate the word cute to be pronounced i
mean to be associated with them but this
is not a bad thing yeah cute shrimp what
nicki i'm kidding i'm kidding i'm sorry
but what
is it
well there goes another fake profile
talking [ __ ] on us um
so i when i say cute i i i'm not saying
like oh cute little boy no it's more
saying like warm i feel safe with you
yeah yeah that's exactly endearing yeah
if i were to date you i'd feel safe i
feel like you're sweet yeah lovable you
probably go out and get me like a
surprise snack or something he looks
like a sweet guy this smile is welcoming
yeah it's like it's like uh you're i'm
not gonna just [ __ ] you and leave i kind
of i want to marry you like i see us at
a baseball game together oh because of
the hat yeah maybe yeah you girls fell
in love off of one guy
we're talking about the first time i do
love his teeth he's got great teeth a
guy with great teeth like will like get
way more of a chance for me it's also
his cheat like the way his face like
forms with his smile it's so warm and
inviting yeah and he's so like
like endearing it's not fake like he
doesn't have the dead eyes yeah this is
blessing
there's a lot of guys with the shark
guys the dead shark eyes and he doesn't
have he has soft eyes yeah yeah this is
the guy that you marry and he can grow a
full ass beard his beard connects he
looks like the guy that he's got his
hair full cry at the altar when you're
reading your vows i want that if my man
doesn't crash
i'm going back
yeah no for sure let's see more photos i
want to see more photos whether it's
saving more and spending less getting
organized or losing weight there are a
lot of worthwhile goals to set for
yourself this year at the top of my list
is learning a new language with babel
the language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions you guys i
have been learning french in my free
time my favorite time to do babble is
when i take a bath at the end of the
night i get to sit there and practice my
bonjour while i'm taking a bath and
getting all bubbly and feeling cute it's
the best way to wind down but also use
my brain a little bit in a different way
than i have throughout the rest of the
day because the rest of the day i'm
wasting my brain scrolling through
instagram and i feel a little bit better
about myself if i spend a few minutes
trying to learn something and stretch my
brain with the language learning babel
teaches bite-sized language lessons for
real-world use their 15-minute lessons
make it the perfect way to learn a new
language on the go other language
learning apps used ai for their lesson
plans but babel lessons were created by
over 100 language experts their teaching
method has been scientifically proven to
be effective with babel you can choose
from 14 different languages including
spanish french italian and german plus
babel's speech recognition technology
helps you to improve your pronunciation
and accent there are so many ways to
learn with babble in addition to lessons
you can access podcasts games videos
stories and even live classes and it
comes with a 20-day money-back guarantee
there is no risk start your new language
learning journey today with babel right
now when you purchase a three-month
babel subscription you'll get an
additional three months for free that is
six months of babble for the price of
three just go to babel.com and use promo
code big mood that's b a b b e l
code big mood babble
language for life you guys already know
what food delivery apps are so i'm not
going to patronize you and try to
explain what doordash is what i'm going
to tell you is doordash is the best
freaking app
in the space
if you don't have doordash what are you
doing say it again for the people i
don't know what you're doing you need to
switch just stop using the other ones at
least for a day try doordash because
it's my favorite one and i'm telling you
this i'm not even freaking kidding quit
scrolling around doordash has saved my
life all the people that work for
doordash at least in my city are on top
of their [ __ ] yeah they deliver on time
and very well and they follow directions
unlike some other apps i don't know the
i don't know what's going on name names
we're not gonna name any names but
doordash is amazing i've been moving and
i didn't have time to go grocery store
and now doordash they added groceries
yeah so you can get groceries and you
can get food from wendy's and chipotle
there's been so many times like where
i've gotten stuff from cvs and then you
can like add on orders from 7 11 or
whatever like you can do like you can do
multiple orders at once
what do i want to eat today pills and
the slurpee
no but like you can do it like doordash
does it all yeah doordash does it all
does it all we love doorknobs
doordash till i die
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15 or more when you
download the doordash app and enter code
mood that's 25 off up to 10 value and
zero delivery fees on your first order
when you download the doordash app in
the app store and enter code mood dude
don't forget the code mood for 25 off
your order with doordash subject to
change terms apply all right uh let's
look at his second post here about me he
says
looking for good connections and fun
times nope open to something casual or
something more serious
my strengths uh he says i'm goal
oriented emotionally intelligent i
always smell good that's oh that's
really good i always smell good i've
never seen anyone put emotionally
intelligent in their profile i like that
yeah man especially
i've never put i've seen anyone put i
always smell good like that's actually
important i like it it's kind of like a
joke but also good to know thank you i
like that because now i'm looking at
your pictures knowing you smell good
yeah because boys have a certain smell
some of them some of them i don't like
that it's a casual profile but that's
just where i'm at he said or
i know but then the thing on the thing
in my basic info it says i don't know if
you can see it but towards the bottom it
says taurus but right above that that
little thing is a magnifying glass and
it stands for what are you looking for
and it says i don't know yet well he's
when he says something casual but i'm
like that's basically like you're
opening the door all you want is hookups
but you just threw in maybe something
serious to kind of like bait the girls
into thinking that you might be open to
a relationship that's how you've never
been on dates
i'm telling you this is what they're
[ __ ] doing and i'm only going off of
if i were to set one up today you're
believing people you're you would get
eaten like know i'm saying i might put
don't you would get eaten like a shrimp
girl even if i was serious i know she
was like well i don't know yet like
maybe i want to get to know some people
first before of course i mean that's
generally how things go right but when
you spell it out like i want something
casual but maybe something serious it's
like it's baiting the girls that are
like oh i want a relationship so you
said maybe a relationship right it was a
red flag for you yeah for me the red
flag part was how he listed his
strengths i i personally found it kind
of like
like he was he was kind of baiting with
that like how do the fact that he put
like i always smell good it's like it
just doesn't sound really genuine it
sounds braggy
i took it as humorous yeah yeah i like
it well because of everything else
because of like the whole thing being
put it's not funny it's not
there's no jokes in there
and then so to me i read that as like
he's being really arrogant like with
especially with the emotionally
intelligent part where i'm like i don't
know just didn't come off really humble
yeah it came off really like braggy to
me and and i didn't even pick up on the
part that just picked up but yeah i
didn't pick up on what you're saying and
she's analyzing it so i i agree with her
too yeah like that could be like a
baiting thing just because just because
of how i read the strengths part being a
baiting thing and i didn't pick up on
either of those but i was like taurus oh
no that's not going to work
sorry casey
i like how everyone finds one thing in
there yeah i don't like that yeah
yeah it describes us so well you know
why we're here it was that's so funny
we're not an echo chamber it's it's like
it's like we you now you know exactly
what's most important to each [ __ ] here
uh i i personally like the emotionally
intelligent i always smell good but i
see it on tiff's side too it's like the
emotionally intelligent side do you
really have to put it out there exactly
yes it feels weird caught up oriented
didn't bother me because yeah that's the
part where like yeah you can say
i don't even know how to even put it
into words but like that's okay to brag
yeah so
people aren't goal oriented like they're
just happy to kind of like see where the
wind takes them and then they just like
to like i'll do this until it doesn't
work and then i'll do that and then also
it kind of contradicts to me too like
you're goal-oriented with your
personal stuff or like your career
probably but then you're just looking
for the relationship
yeah
the emotionally intelligent part it's
the same thing as if you wrote
intelligent like that doesn't like no
one would put like they're iq yeah i'm
goal oriented intelligent beautiful and
you know
it could be intertwined with the
relationship baiting because you know
that like girls want a guy that's
emotionally intelligent and you're maybe
kind of relationship baiting but you're
actually just out looking for sex right
what if he replaced emotionally
intelligent with um i don't know like
understanding or
i could even like for me listener good
listener it would it would work yeah
good listener but for me like the i
always smell good and what
i would have written if i was him and i
was being genuine i would have just been
like i've been told i smell good like
that sounds more like
like you know like this is something
about me that has been brought to my
attention not that i'm like all [ __ ]
yeah i know i smell good i don't know i
saw it as a i took it as humorous
immediately yes same because i saw it as
he has he he listed three things serious
serious and then yes exactly that's how
you make it too serious yeah it's like
an email where you throw in a few
exclamation points in there just to make
it light and so just serious all the
time you know
excellent
okay uh wait what was the rest so he's 5
10. uh he is he is 5 foot 10 he works
out sometimes he drinks socially he
smokes weed socially uh he doesn't know
what he's looking for yet um he's
he wants children someday he's a taurus
and he's agnostic yes interests include
volleyball cafe hopping anime oh he's a
weeb foodie and confidence that's an
interesting stupid interest why would
they why would that be you know that's
an option yeah well i i mean it kind of
makes sense to me like you're attracted
to people that have confidence yeah it's
like
an interest it's like you're listening
though it's like why is that yeah yeah
that's not a little bit
set up if you have it yeah yeah we don't
need that oh he's fast take that one out
yeah take out the confidence thing
because if you have to label it put it
put it out there somewhere it just feels
like you're projecting it not that you
actually have it like you'll be able
people will can know if you're confident
interested in confidence he's interested
that other people have oh maybe uh other
people haven't come no that's how i read
it
like an interesting hobby though
yeah there's still a weird thing to list
as an interest that's a pick something
else pick music or something else more
pictures i think i think that's an
actual like one of those default options
that you can choose on the website but
you know for sure it seems like it is an
option but it is weird why would you
change it why something else pick like
an actual thing that you like movies
music something else because it just
comes off as weird oh next one no get
rid of this photo yeah i don't like none
of that
at all i don't like this photo at all he
looks like he's in high school like a
freshman in high school he definitely
looks way too young in this like
immature kinda yeah like you're just
loitering what he has that haircut that
i [ __ ] hate oh that's like watches
yes
i'm so sorry
is this a new term i learned in chicano
world because now i the only the only
way i'm tapped in is through instagram
so they're like the
the new version of like the mexican kids
at school it's like chicano kids that
have that haircut they drive trucks
they're [ __ ]
fuckboys like the mexican [ __ ] boys
oh okay yeah that's how i understand it
i could be wrong i don't know gene is
over here googling [ __ ]
you i think it would be a cute no it's a
queue
yeah it's a q right there at the bottom
oh no wait keep going tacorias no it's
not shrimp taquerias
that's a taco
it's true
right there that's what it is
they're always saying dude that guy
lives right next to me
he screams on his windows
yeah
i i'm so sorry like nikki's butler
i i don't know any other way to say this
please i'm i do i'm saying this because
i want to help you i [ __ ] hate that
haircut so much because and that's
something that can be changed yes
haircuts can be changed here's the thing
i like so you have a great face guy like
with guys the haircut changes so yeah
that's their makeup basically you change
your beard or your hair that's your
whole makeup that's it but the fact that
he has this haircut to me only
solidifies what jess was saying about
the baiting he's [ __ ] relationship
baby boy yeah [ __ ] boy because it's an
earlier haircut [ __ ] boy like earlier
today
how you feel about shrimp
now they're really coming down on you
i went from five ten thousand
yeah it's so sweet and like yeah
i went from these [ __ ] can turn on
you in a millisecond yeah you don't know
she's so loyal to here
i went from he's so sweet i want a date
with a date yeah you want to marry him i
want to marry him in this one picture
this one picture i want to bully the
[ __ ] out of you
i'm so sorry look because
okay first of all we get a third photo
live photo i want to see
photos of your face i don't know what
you look like these are so far away yeah
i think they're closed i still love his
smile the hair even looks better now
because he didn't all messed up his hair
it's not like a perfect one straight
yeah
right until here and here to here and
it's just
it makes his his his forehead be one in
why does the explorer have a [ __ ]
beard
oh you asked for this i don't know
oh you're too you're 22 years old you're
too old for this [ __ ] haircut bro
like never yeah should a man have
straight
bangs i'm laughing but like the thing is
like you can you can kind of grow up and
get a better haircut and you'll be fine
bro like just the haircut
whereas i'm only roasting you because
it's you can change it you can fix it
she's helping you yeah she's giving you
tough love here exactly you know but
he's got his style like he's got swag he
just i mean but just the haircut is just
killing it you know he he is a fan of
this show and you're about to not be a
fan of me but then yeah you will be you
will be he's no longer a fan of our show
he's never really never committed to
anyone so yeah look at that that may be
so good just stop doing that don't you
were right initially that's true he says
he never writes to me i know i thought
that's so bad sorry but gina is showing
her we are giving you a tough love this
is tough love and would you get that
haircut i don't know get a comb over oh
he would look so good with that comb
over here come over so what is that
undercut a side part side sweep
we need to see more of your forehead
once you get that haircut and you get
all the [ __ ] you're going to love us
you understand he's got a good adam's
apple that's really attractive to a lot
of females what does he is what is he
saying yeah oh look he likes roasting
roasted he says you want a perfect
balance of beans there we go and simply
it says swipe right if you want that
perfect balance between roasting and
simping for each other he can handle it
he can handle it because i'm roasting
you now once you get that haircut i'll
sing for you mm-hmm
and then the last part says
two truths and a lie ooh i want to guess
all right um the two truths and eliza is
i've taken a solo trip to japan
i know how to cook and i tried stealing
hubba bubba gum as a kid and got caught
you don't know how to cook
you didn't go to japan because if you
did you would not have that haircut you
would you would be cultured
i feel like they have worse haircuts in
japan i don't know
if a weak character has that haircut
they have it in japan okay because
doesn't he like anime too uh he does i
believe that he went to japan i just
noticed something according to his
location he might have a an english
accent maybe it's a beatles haircut ah
he's doing maybe it's a haircut that's
cool like in europe they have a a
european taco
stop singing
because it makes me laugh
that's a fun word well if he's from
england he definitely doesn't know how
to cook because i've tasted their food
in the whole [ __ ] country except you
know like indian food is really good
over there so is he oh he looks like an
ethnic of some sort so maybe he's indian
because the indian people could [ __ ]
cook something
true maybe he didn't steal but can he
cook it
i think he did steal the hubba bubba
gumbo because anyone specific anyone
that explains in that much details yeah
it means you probably or they lied in
part of it like they tried stealing it
and they didn't get caught maybe do you
know what i mean yeah it's like there's
so much too much detail part it's like
if it's fifty percent a lie it still
counts as a lie
or maybe he's never been to japan let me
taste your cooking get haircut
that's right hey nikki's butler i know
you're gonna watch this uh leave in the
comments tell us which one was actually
no because then he's gonna be like no
you guys are gonna know which what's my
youtube page we'll leave it from the
hate account that you're gonna create
for us
screenshots reply to the video no look
sir nicki's butler we like you we just
want you to get a haircut and we think
you'll be good i'm sure i feel like
honestly you're probably already [ __ ]
like hella girls but like maybe you can
get a a better level of girls uh if you
cut the good different haircut change
your star sign
oh my god you're starting today you were
born that's enough of you nikki's butler
um i'll just get another girl he's like
all you guys did was roast me you didn't
even help me other than getting a
haircut all he needs is a haircut that's
all
that's a good thing his prompts are good
he's actually got good fashion he just
needs a different haircut yeah
or like at least slick it back like let
me see your forehead and she doesn't
like that you're you don't know what you
want well i mean he's 22. that's fine
he's not in my age range that's okay
that's fine but it's just the haircut
that's it that's all you got to do i'll
then mow you money for a haircut baby
i'm trying to help all right like i'm
doing whatever i can to help you okay
okay
the next profile what's her name
jellybean 23. there we go
bean 23 says hi big mood i love your
content and i'd appreciate your feedback
on my dating profile i've been single
since the pandemic started and all this
time plus your show has helped me grow
yeah
yay okay so jelly bean let's look at the
first photo jelly bean here is fine oh
my gosh so pretty
well [ __ ] what exactly do you want to
know from us she works in an accounting
too
she's an accountant it's a secretary at
accounting firm 21 years old secretariat
and accounting yeah she's got tattoos
she's beautiful
she's really very symmetrical i love
your eyebrows
she has great eyebrows wow
this is a great first pretty good
opening wonderful very first picture
wonderful first picture that's better
than any of mine on my phone on my
profile and on her screenshot her
battery's fully almost fully charged
amazing
responsible we love a fully charged
battery profile yeah
um okay the next photo we oh the next
thing is about her she says
what's it mean tiff welcome okay
uh sucker for cute things movies and
tattoos she is five foot six she's a
capricorn she's in college she drinks
and smokes socially and she doesn't know
what she wants in her in this yet yeah
she doesn't know what she's looking for
yet and her interests are dancing
concerts crime
crime television
uh being romantic and feminism but if
it's just she likes crying
together
looking for the clients
what's your interest
dancing concerts and
committing burglary and arson
federal
felonies
just kidding okay being romantic how
cute are we going to give her the same
[ __ ] as we did for the other guys
absolutely
yes
absolutely
we're not gonna give her a [ __ ] for that
no i wasn't i was 22. he was 22 the last
guy so i gave him a pass okay because
he's she's 21.
see in your early 20s it's okay to not
know what you're looking for but in your
[ __ ] 30s it's a little old it's
always okay it's just a little old
you're giving yourself a clean slate
what if you were just divorced yeah true
then you shouldn't be you should be
healing on your own not [ __ ] dragging
people into your don't tell people
divorce a gatekeeper hasn't been done no
i'm saying if you're divorcing what i've
been through
when you're divorced and you're going
through all of your emotional [ __ ] you
don't bring in someone who's ready for a
relationship and [ __ ] their world
because you're not ready for it i'm open
[ __ ] yeah
so you know the last guy he wrote his
interests were confidence
this chick wrote her interest being
yeah like you don't have anything but i
did realize that there was a double
standard because my first reaction was
how cute yeah and then the other guy was
like weird well because that's a cute
thing being romantic is cute and it's a
dating thing yeah it's like how you're
gonna show up in your relationship
that's true it is a dating thing i mean
so it's confidence yeah but there's
different yeah confidence is like so uh
up for it's so objective like maybe
that's like well that's what you're
attracted to you're attracted to be
romantic maybe no i don't know okay uh
next slide oh my god look at that smile
really pretty
do you like her eyes she bottled it at
disney
she put i modeled at disney as a preteen
selena gomez is my distant cousin and a
lady paid me to karate kick her kid wow
that's good so specific that it's
probably true that last one i'm gonna
say selena gomez is the lie yeah yeah
because maybe she gets compared to her a
lot like yeah
she kind of looks like it could be but
if i have famouses and cousins i
wouldn't use them on my profile
yeah like i wouldn't say like mine no
it's like just people
like chase people like that some people
like the clout though like oh selena
gomez is your cousin that's [ __ ]
tight
i just wouldn't want people to want to
ask more questions about my cousin than
me just makes you seem like a shitty
cousin yeah yeah exactly you're using
her
i hope that's the lie
cool
i'm really intrigued by um a lady paid
me to karate kick her kid because i feel
like she might be in martial arts but
she wants a word a weird way yeah yeah
to be funny because when people ask me
what i do i say i do things on camera
for money yeah yeah and they're like oh
like it's a funny way to say you gotta
ask more questions about it taught in
karate class that'd be super [ __ ]
cool yeah yeah
and modeled it disney as a preteen the
preteen detail of it sounds like legit
yeah and she's so pretty that it seems
obvious that she would get booked at
disney she's got good teeth her eyeliner
is really nice and she blends her eyes
she's got a good face i love it already
her face is good
the next slide oh she's cute well she's
at disneyland there there we go
she's a disney person yeah i like that
that's not my thing i'm sorry i can't
date someone who's like no if she was
dressed as minnie mouse at disneyland
that's a disney person oh yeah this is
like she's casual she just went to
disneyland wait is that the disney
ferris wheel because it doesn't have a
big mickey mouse face yeah no there was
a time where they didn't have the mickey
mouse face on it so i mean this is 2021
it says it might not be oh yeah it's
probably not because in the bottom half
of it too yeah oh it's vegas i think is
it maybe is it the eye it could be a
pier that has a i don't know i have a
ferris wheel on it but it's a cute photo
too yeah i like that she's including her
face so we get a clear shot of what she
looks like no mystery all of them have
yeah shots of the face i like the colors
oh and then the body shots body shot
guys will definitely like that um oh
yeah i'm still not over the zodiac
killer being ted cruz
wait what does that mean what's that
right
so there's an ongoing joke that i'm glad
we have a [ __ ]
z lineal representative
as a gen z interpreter my client says
that she's uh she's
the zodiac killer is ted cruz because
there's an ongoing joke that ted cruz is
the zodiac killer and they're just
making stupid memes like the look how
they're connected
yeah
like a joke conspiracy it's a joke or is
it like do people really believe this oh
no it's a joke conspiracy though because
it's not even the same time frame huh or
is it but they harass him like on his
comments and stuff like why are you the
zodiac killer and i don't know i think
from what i heard he hates it so i'm
sure he does
she has a sense of humor yeah yeah and
she's definitely on the internet that's
for sure the next slide is oh i don't
like that it's sideways can you flip it
yeah it's true i don't like that after
work you can find me animal crossing or
cog she plays games
all right gina jean is one over now yeah
gina's girl she plays animal crossings
okay i like that she's a gamer she's a
nerd and obviously from the previous
comments she's an internet nerd yeah so
this is gina yeah a different life form
yeah this isn't a different life form
yeah
me but different fonts she's you yeah
i do wish the photo was flipped yeah
yeah i mean like maybe it's artistic or
something but also just like annoying a
little bit yeah
uh overall you should not be having any
trouble getting dick
[Music]
okay i don't think she does mm-hmm she's
a cutie and i like oh look at that
profile photo yeah that's really good i
feel like some of those should be more
on the dating profile too because like
they're all a little bit too similar
just like selfies but like some of these
other ones like the
instagram profile photo yeah is so like
beautiful and fun yes i like that one
you should put that on there and
replace it replace the sideway
no replace one of the first two because
they were the first couple were the same
i like the first shot
the one down like below uh go that one
and the other one had the same smile
like the ferris wheel and that one i
think the ferris wheel one we don't need
yeah use that instagram profile shot yep
because the ferris wheel one's also not
lit very well and it's the same exact
face from the previous photo
that could go on your instagram they
have tagged
and the profile thing you gotta give
them variety variety variety you know
what like i guess a critique i would
give is um i don't see enough of her
personality like i don't really know
her really that's true she
actually like what we're gonna do if we
go hang out yeah you have no idea like
what direction it's going in like i get
it that she listed her interests like
she's into tattoos or whatever right
like she has she has like a sense of
humor with the zodiac killer thing but
like
yeah like i i guess i i would want more
like what are your hobbies like what do
you like how do you spend your time well
it said call of duty like when she's at
home she likes to play games yeah that's
like just online that it was written in
there but i think with the photos i
personally would like i appreciate more
of when the photos show me personality
i get the the i appreciate the zodiac
killer ted cruz joke thing
not but it kind of flies over a lot of
people's heads yeah i i feel like choose
a better prompt where you can answer
with something that tells us more about
you yeah just like an internet i think
what a lot of girls probably do is like
they don't want to come off as being too
serious and so like they don't they
really just treat the profile as like
throw away so they don't make so it
doesn't look like they care that much
like i don't care if you like me i mean
i'm just here to play i'm just [ __ ]
around you know like just it's kind of
like a handicap and then like a barrier
to like
well i'm just [ __ ] around it's just
whatever it's just a throwaway like i'm
not really trying that hard defense
mechanism yeah maybe the quality of
people you're gonna get swept on you
yeah so just add a little bit more so if
you do want a relationship then maybe
you could like actually show be a little
bit more
uh what's the word like uh like
vulnerable vulnerable yeah maybe maybe
she doesn't but if you really don't feel
like you want a relationship then i
think this is this is the right college
yeah i mean if she's in college she's
just too busy to give up
yeah it's just like are you aware that
that could be yeah the type of people
that you're attracting are people that
are gonna be more into your looks than
anything yeah but i mean regardless her
looks are there so like if you want
something more
guys will kind of put you in like a oh
she's showing only maybe like how that
she's just pretty and i'm not getting a
whole lot else or then if you show a
little bit more then they'll be like oh
i see like personality too like she's
hot and then also she's like yeah but if
you feel something about uh the type of
person you're trying to attract it'll
attract them you know like yeah if i'm
giving you like little a little bit more
about um call of duty or a little bit
more about true crime stuff or like more
details about it then it might induce
more conversation i appreciate the call
of duty thing okay so listen i got more
important things to do right now because
baby's starting to kick yes so i'm gonna
wrap it up this is important i hate
everyone else here about this baby
so thank you for sending in your
profiles
and thank you make sure you follow us on
big mood girls on instagram because we
post you know promises
yeah and we love seeing your actual
faces and hearing your actual voices and
it's it's really nice i'm surprised at
how i know a lot of you how hot a lot of
people have listeners
better looking than me
it's truly a hot line out here
except for you whatever daddy you knock
yourself down a few notches we should
start a dating service and match our
fans
the first one in this girl right here
hey listen if you're you might be
interested and you guys want to link up
let dm us we'll just say yeah
if you guys get married after hooking up
from our show like we're invited to the
wedding so yeah for sure just let us
just letting you know um thank you i'm
not sorry for anything that i said today
make sure you guys check out all of our
sponsors uh give us a thumbs up give us
five stars rate us make us make it
awesome let us know if you agree with
our
stuff that we said about let us know if
you're interested in any of these hot
people
pass along the message we'll look it up
after once his name gets a haircut okay
see you next week bye
[Music]
you